I'm saying man you gotta leave America
to grow up every time I go to India I
grow up a little bit this last time I
went to the Taj Mahal and that was it
was eye-opening man I don't know if
anybody's ever been but it's the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen whole
thing made a white marble then like
emeralds and sapphires and rubies just
inlaid throughout the whole thing took I
believe twenty-two thousand workers
twenty years non-stop to build it and
I'm telling you when I went to my
country and saw my people build
something like that I realized America
completely wasted their slaves
we can [ __ ] Bobby what are you doing
stupid thing to do build something you
know look I'm not saying slavery's of
slavery's the worst I'm saying American
slavery is the wharf slavery and it's
all bad look when Indian slaves but all
the thoughts all of it cut off our hands
after so we can never make anything that
beautiful again
that's [ __ ] up at the same time we
don't need to make anything that
beautiful again these two owners in the
world this is greedy there's a pride you
know I mean we built that and they think
you're the Jewish dude walking through
Egypt looking at the pyramids you would
be like yo man that's [ __ ] up what
they did to us but we kill this [ __ ]
no does the big package is doing it who
says we can't do manual labor black
people we're gonna have to get pride do
socks
no no it's got an extra cushion in this
terrible man that's why black people
deserve reparations black Americans
deserve reparations well I agree man
Indians don't ask for him because we
already built ours you one of the
thousand of all that money goes back at
us have you ever seen white tourists
stay in this picture
then money goes back in our pockets we
got our reparations maybe we'll have a
mini something we gotta figure it out I
think I was gonna say that she can make
money off longer wearing underwear I saw
Scott Michael Jordan got that let him
have it
the perfect reparations for black people
I figured it out they should get 10% of
all chewing tobacco sales it's perfect
first of all black who had to pick
[ __ ] tobacco leaves for hundreds of
years awful thing so they should make
some money on it
second you know who loves chewing
tobacco
[Applause]
I do thank you
so what bad way to make money off the
dentist's embraces son all right I'm
gonna get going my name is Akash
[Applause]
[Music]